In the chaos of the last few months,
I've put a lot of things on hold,
not just the blog.
Also my writing it.
Since those two things sort of go hand
in hand,
I want to start both up at the same
time.
So I started working on a third book,
which I'm really excited about.
Art Saifai.
I've also started a new tumbler called
52 bucks,
52 weeks in which it's exactly what it
sounds like.
The idea is that the people I work with
are way more knowledgeable than me,
so this is how you know I will destroy
them.
I feel I've gotten into Lincoln,
the dubliner.
I've also started working on a new
album.
What?
You make music.
Yes,
but you already knew that
interesting,
simple and unprofessional music,
but know it makes me really happy and
creative and I'll put it on soundcloud
when it's done.
Now you might be saying nerdwriter,
you have a job now,
aren't you putting too many things on
your plate too?
Which you know,
I can only say yes.
I don't know.
I figure what's the use of having an
appropriately full plate on the back?
Mom,
I just press the red bugging me.
Recording.
Yeah.
Okay.
One more time.
Ready?
Shelly,
are you the one?
I know it's videoing now.
You're videoing.
Ready?
Cool.
Lily.
Lily,
are you ready?